Dr. Ramos here
again, great
to connect with you all.
These are the session
objectives for this
lecture taken directly
from the CPG. So
I won't spend any
time, you know, going
over this. You can
read them on your own
and then try to connect
what's written in
the objectives with
what I described and
how to connect those
dots. All right, the
session objectives
here are the kind of
the big picture, the
big picture overview
of the details that
we'll be presenting.
All right, hopefully
most of you have
just finished
watching the intro, my
earlier lecture,
which emphasizes the
histology and the
major cellular players
of the nervous system.
This is an important
next step of
information to
understanding how neurons
work in the brain.
we're going to be
focusing on the electrical
activity of neurons
and their connections.
So like many cells in
the body, neurons are
electrically excitable,
just like muscle
and just like other
parts, other organs
that you'll learn
about. And the reason
they're excitable
is obviously because
the inside and the
outside of the cells
contain many ions,
right? And ions have
electrical charge.
They can be cationic,
anionic, have one or
two charges, right?
And on top of that,
there are ion channels
and other transporters
and whatnot
that allow for dynamic
movement of ions
inside and outside,
into and out of the
cell, right? Which
carry their charge and
then are going to
change the signature
electrical potential
of the of the cell.
So the resting
membrane potential of a
neuron, meaning in the
absence of any kind
of excitation, the
resting membrane
potential of a neuron
is very hyperpolarized,
meaning more
negative relative to
zero and relative
to the extracellular
side. We're going
to cover in the next
couple of slides why
is the resting membrane
potential negative
and how does that
relate to neuronal
communication, right?
And the resting
membrane potential is
about minus 65 in
most CNS cells but
can vary quite can
vary quite a bit.
But minus 65 is a
good starting point.
And membrane potential
physiology is important
in other organ
systems. So this is
hopefully setting
the foundations of an
understanding of membrane
physiology that will
serve you well. For
example, when you cover
cardiovascular histology
and physiology.
All right.
Neuronal resting
membrane potential
is hyperpolarized,
about minus 65.
Where does that come
from? It comes to
be for a number of
factors. Number one,
the sodium-potassium
ATPase. Remember
that this pump found
on the membrane
of neurons is
shuttling three sodium
ions out of the cell
and pumping in two
potassium ions into
the cell, right?
And so you can see here
that three positive
charges are leaving,
only two are coming in.
So when more positive
leaves, that's
essentially going to make
the cell more negative.
It's like if you have
a bank account and
you spend $3 every week,
but you only take in
two dollars, right,
you're going to have a
net negative effect
on your account. So
that's one factor. Number
two is that there are
membrane channels
that are selectively
permeable to potassium
and sodium that are open
and leaky at rest.
These are often called
the leak potassium and
leak sodium channels
right so these channels
are always open at
rest and so what happens
since potassium is
at high concentration
inside the cell this
leaky channel is causing
potassium to leave
right and when potassium
leaves it's um it's
removing positive
charge from inside the
cell. There are also
leak sodium channels and
remember sodium is
at high concentration
outside the cell. Now
sodium is coming in in
that scenario flowing
into the cell which
would make it more positive
inside but it turns
out there are 40
times more leak K than
leak sodium channels
or the contribution of
leak potassium ions,
ion flow or leak K
channels being open is
40 times more than leak
sodium channels. All
right. And so recall
also in the background
of all this is the fact
that there are unequal
concentration of
ions inside and outside
the cell. And anytime
an ion is at high
concentration, it's going
to want to go down
its concentration
gradient, right? So this
is why K wants to leave
the cell, sodium wants
to enter the cell,
chloride wants to
enter the cell, and
calcium wants to
enter the cell,
right? And in this
little chart here.
Where is my cursor?
In this little
chart here, we have
concentrations of the
major ions at play in
neurons. We have
outside the cell and
inside the cell. And
notice how K is low
outside the cell, but
sodium and chloride
and calcium are all
high outside the
cell, so they want
to go into the cell.
I am aware of a
lecture that you got
earlier in the course
that talked about a
little bit of concentration
gradients, ion
flow, the Nernst
equation, right, the
Nernst equation, and
the Nernst equation
gives us an understanding
of where the
membrane potential
wants to rest at in the
presence of only one
ion that has unequal,
in the presence of
one, in the presence
of a cell that has
permeability to an ion
where the ion
concentrations are different
inside and outside
the cell. In other
words, if the cell
is permeable to K and
K is at high concentration
inside versus
outside at this ratio,
let's say 5 to 100
millimolar, then that
cell will want to
rest at about minus
80 millivolts, right?
When you combine
the differences in
concentration and
you combine the
influence of the sodium
potassium pump and
leak potassium
channels, leak sodium
channels, what we're
gonna run here.
All right so I'm
gonna play this
this video and in
this video we have
the inside the
cell, outside of the
cell, and we're
gonna put our players
here. We have our
leak channels,
sodium, and potassium.
Remember potassium is
about 40 times more
leaky than sodium and
we're putting our sodium
potassium ATPase.
We're changing our
concentrations. Remember
Na is low on the inside,
very high on the outside.
Potassium is high
on the inside and very
low on the outside.
All right, and now
these are our players
here. We're going to
simulate how a neuron
would respond and how
its membrane potential,
where it would go.
And when I hit play
you're going to see
where that membrane
potential is going to
go in this scenario.
Where does it go? It
goes to minus 65. And
what's happening is we
have our leak sodium
channel, leak potassium
channel, and our
sodium potassium ATPase.
When we play this
again, take a look at
how we have a lot more
potassium leaving
the cell than we have
sodium. Take a look at
our sodium potassium
ATPase pumping
out more sodium
than it's pumping
in potassium.
Okay, and you
could play this a
couple more times
if you need a
little more need
this to kind of
Visualize this
a little better.
So this is the kind of
Physiology
that's underlying
neurons at rest, right?
Well as other cell
types and other parts of
the body you'll learn
about resting membrane
potential of muscle
of cardiac cells, etc
all right so kind of
this is a somewhat
again a repetition but
important to make sure
that we we understand
where's my cursor
here that leak K channels
contribute quite a
bit to the resting
to the hyperpolarized
resting membrane potential
but there is some
contribution of the
leak sodium channels
right if K channels were
the only if K channels
were the only ionic
conductance right
well then the resting
membrane potential would
be at minus 80 which
is the potassium
equilibrium potential
but it's not right so
that means that there is
a contribution of leak
channels right to
push it a little bit
more close move it more
towards move it from
minus 80 to about
minus 65 all right and
that difference in
permeability or influence
from potassium to
sodium is about 40 to 1.
And like you saw in the
simulation, all these
numbers are not that
important for you
to memorize, but for
you to understand how
reproducible and how
well we understand these
phenomenons at least
at this at this level
okay all right so in
conclusions neurons
exhibit a negative
resting membrane potential
due to those factors
again sodium potassium
ATPase leaky channels
differences in the
permeability between
these leaky channels
and of course in the
background is you know
the basic principles
of you know ions at
different concentration
right that they want
to go down their
concentration gradient but
and also there is you
know an electrical
gradient right that's
that's also in the
background so positive
and negative charges of
course attract all
right so in contrast to
this concept that I
that we want you to get
you everyone to
understand is kind of the
resting membrane potential
in addition to that
we have to talk about
now when the neuron
is electrically active
and and that signature
activity is called
the action potential
all right so the
action potential is the
electrical and chemical
signal that neurons
use to initiate a
conversation with the next
cell that with the
postsynaptic cell all
right it's the language
of neurons, and it is
the vehicle by which
then the chemical
messengers, the
neurotransmitters, can be
released, which then
transmit information from
one cell to the other,
or from one neuron to
muscle, or from one
neuron to a gland, or
from one neuron to release
a chemical messenger
into the circulation,
for example, to
then target another
organ in the periphery.
All right?
So we said that
neurons at rest are at
about minus 65. But if
a neuron is depolarized,
meaning depolarization,
meaning going
more positive or
closer to zero and past
zero, for example, If
a neuron is depolarized
to about minus 40
millivolts, so from
minus 65 to about
minus 40, then bang,
you'll get an action
potential, right? So the
action potential is a
very brief electrical
change in the membrane
potential of the
neuron. And we have
the classic recording
done here in the
squid, right? So all
living things that have
behavior have neurons
that exhibit action
potentials, right?
So this was in the squid
giant axon recorded
by Hodgkin and Huxley
that got them the
Nobel Prize. And here
we have a nice kind of
schematic of the action
potential, right?
So we can see that in
this schematic, our
neuron is resting right
about minus 65 here,
right? And then we have
depolarization past
zero, and then
repolarization and
hyperpolarization, and
then we get to a membrane
potential that is back
at resting levels.
And notice how this
entire event, if we say
maybe it's starting
right about here and
ending, let's say right
about here or so this
whole event was about
you know less than
three milliseconds okay
and in some neurons
it could be even
faster faster than that
okay so action potentials
we'll see in a second
are generated by the
activation of voltage
gated sodium and
potassium channels these
are different than
the leak, sodium, and
potassium channels we
talked about a couple
minutes ago. These are
voltage-gated, meaning
we need the voltage
to get to a certain
level, and then these
channels will open,
all right? And the
action potential travels
down the axon, right?
Like the axon being
a wire transmitting
this electrical signal
and will cause
neurotransmitter release
at the synapse.
So let's look at
more of the players
now in the physiology
of neurons using
another simulation.
Alright so here we
have our simulation
interface again and we're
going to be adding more
players to our
membrane. We're going to
be adding these sodium
potassium ATPase, we're
going to add our leak
potassium channel,
our leak sodium channel.
We're going to be
adding a voltage-gated
potassium channel and
a voltage-gated sodium
channel, okay? All
right, so we're adding
our leak channels.
We said they're at
40 to 1 difference.
We're adding our sodium
potassium ATPase.
We're adding our
sodium channel.
we're adding our
voltage-gated
potassium channel.
We're going to make
sure our concentrations
are correct.
A is high inside the
cell and then what we
need to do is we need
to zap our neuron a
little bit, stimulate
our neuron. We're
going to stimulate
it twice to see if we
depolarize the cell with
our with our stimulation
what what happens
and here we have our
membrane voltage that
we're recording with
an oscilloscope
okay so we have our
resting membrane
potential players active
and these are quiet
we're gonna zap the
cell in a little bit
and then we'll see
what we get oh we got
an action potential.
All right, so I'm
slowing down the video.
During this
resting phase, we
have our resting
membrane potential
players up doing
their thing.
We're going to
depolarize the cell
enough to to trigger
voltage gated sodium
channels to open
here it comes here
it comes that lets
sodium in did you see
also how potassium
started to come out right
and so what what is
happening sodium ions
are rushing into the
cell through these volt
through this voltage
-gated channel and
when sodium rushes in
it's going to depolarize
the cell right and it
wants to depolarize
itself to its equilibrium
potential which
is very positive around
plus 40 right but
then this voltage
-gated potassium channel
opens because its
voltage of activation has
been met during that
depolarizing phase.
And this voltage-gated
channel opens. Well,
what happens? Potassium
is high inside the
cell. So now that this
is open, potassium can
rush out of the cell.
When potassium rushes
out of the cell, what
is it doing? It's
removing positive
charges, and that's going
to bring the membrane
potential down, right?
Potassium ions want
to be at equilibrium
at about minus
80, so you can see
that little
hyperpolarized dip in the
action potential,
right? So together, this
interplay of all
of these channels,
leak, voltage gated,
in sodium potassium
ATPase are what at
play, you know, in all
neurons and underlie
how they produce
membrane potential change,
excitability changes,
and then use that
to create an action
potential to release
transmitter and send
information down the
next step, either to
a muscle or to a gland
or to some neural
network that's important
for emotions memory
sleep wake hunger
thirst etc right so
what's underlying
brain function are the
neurons and there are
different parts of the
neuron and then the
different ion channels
and and you'll see
receptors and all
that that you know all
right all right play
okay so we talked
about I didn't have a
chance to pause it at
the right at the right
spot but I want you
to notice that our
voltage gated sodium
channel was slightly
different than our
voltage gated potassium
channel in that it has
this one little kind
of gate here all right
this gate is known
as the inactivation
gate it's part of the
protein that produces
an interesting phenomena
about how this this
channel can work
so essentially there
are two kinds of
compartments to the to
the channel to the pore
that are going to
regulate whether ions can
flow through it and
in this case sodium.
So in this
configuration where the
inactivation gate
is open and the
channel pore itself
is closed this is
known as the closed
state and ions
cannot flow through
this state. Okay,
ions can only flow
or this channel
is open when both
the inactivation
gate and this pore
gate are open.
Then ion can flow
through it. We call that
the open state. So
there's a closed state,
the open state, and
notice that there's also
an inactivated state.
In the inactivated state
this inactivation
gate is closed and
basically that shuts down
the channel pore. And
no matter what happens
here, it doesn't matter
if this moves open or
not, this is in the
closed state, this
channel is inactivated.
And voltage gated
sodium channels move
into these different
phases depending
on the membrane
potential, right? So
at rest, voltage
gated sodium channels
are are generally
in the closed state.
Anything that
will raise the
membrane potential
to threshold
will allow the
channel to open,
right? Ions will flow
through, but soon after
the channel opens
and upon further
depolarization, the
inactivation gate will shut and
then this channel can
no longer flux ion.
And only after the
membrane potential is
repolarized again to
a hyperpolarized state
will this inactivation
gate be open. So that's
exactly what happens
during the action
potential, right? We have
all these phases where
some stimulus will
depolarize the cell
enough for it to trigger
an action potential
where these channels
go from closed to open.
And sodium ions that
rush in flow through
and depolarize the cell.
But as the membrane
potential is getting more
and more depolarized,
the inactivation
gates kick in, right,
and sodium ions stop
flowing through the
channel here. At the
same time, we saw that
our voltage-gated
potassium channels open.
Potassium leaves the
cell, causing the
membrane potential to
repolarize, right, and
then even go more
negative than the initial
state because K is
rushing out of the cell.
And so in this way,
sodium channel
inactivation and the
inactivation of
other channels are
really important
in the physiology.
So in summary, voltage
-gated sodium channel
inactivation is
produced by a separate
part of the protein
known as the inactivation
gate, and we mentioned
all this stuff.
Why? Because there
are genetic mutations
that affect the
inactivation gate, which
can result in the
channels being open for
too long. If the
channels are open for too
long, then you have
abnormal excitation,
too much ion flux,
and genetic mutations
affecting the inactivation
gate of sodium
channels produces
brain hyperexcitability
and epilepsy. On top
of that, you'll learn
that there are drugs
that modify channel
inactivation that can
be exploited to speed
up or slow down
inactivation depending on
the disease. And
obviously for something
like epilepsy, you
would want drugs that
increase sodium channel
activation, right?
Okay, so in summary,
there are four
basic components to
the action potential.
We have the rising
phase of initial
rapid depolarization
caused by the
opening of voltage
-gated sodium
channels, right?
That's this part here.
The overshoot
portion is when the
membrane potential
is depolarized
past zero. You
can see that here.
And this is due to
the opening, closing,
and inactivation of
sodium channels, right?
And in particular
more and more
inactivation is now
taking place over
here, as well as the
opening of voltage
-gated potassium
channels, right?
The falling phase
over here is due to
the rapid
hyperpolarization of the
membrane potential
due to more and more
opening of voltage
-gated K channels.
And then the
undershoot, right here,
portion that is more
hyperpolarized than
what the cell was at
rest is due to all this
potassium exiting the
cell and the membrane
potential trying to
go to the equilibrium
potential of potassium
which is at about minus
80 okay so it's it's
a lot I would suggest
kind of going over
over this watching
different parts of this
of these slides again
if necessary and
remember that all of this
Getting kind of this
physiology down and
having this picture in
your mind of ion channels
and the membrane
potential moving up or
down is going to be
really important also
in cardio when you're
learning about atrial
cells or ventricular
cells that each have
their own interesting
membrane potential
physiology that underlies
how they rhythmically
beat and contract,
right? Not to, and how
they produce kind of
their action potentials,
not for communication
like neurons do,
but instead in the
heart for synchronizing,
you know, the contraction
of the tissue to
pump blood out, right?
But, you know, it
all boils down to
understanding the cells,
the ion channels
transporters etc and how they
work in combination
and sequentially etc
whatever the case case
may be all right now
some clinical correlates
obviously anything
that interferes with
the function of any
kind of channel is going
to alter the physiology
and function of that
of that cell that's
in a particular
tissue and organ right
and you're going to
see some manifestation.
So in nature,
there are these ion
channel blockers
that are found
in toxins in
different organisms.
So there is a
bacteria in some fish,
especially in
puffer fish, right,
that is a potent
sodium channel
blocker. That toxin
is known as TTX,
titrototoxin. It's
found in fish.
And so eating
small amounts of
this fish, which
is very dangerous,
is going to alter
the physiology of the
sensory cells in
the mouth. Small
amounts are going
to cause tingling or
numbness as these cells
and their physiology
is being altered
because they can't
generate action
potentials normally.
Eating large amounts
of these fish are going
to cause more widespread
changes centrally
and peripherally. So
like limb weakness,
respiratory failure,
and cardiac arrest.
There are sodium
channels in the heart as
well, like I mentioned.
And so there are
also neurons in the
central nervous system
that help regulate
cardiac function, right?
Virtually all neurons
have sodium channels.
So high levels of TTX
in a person that's
eaten a lot of this
fish could ultimately
cause death, right?
and the mechanism by
that is blocking the
sodium channels. There
is another toxin
found in microbes that
then live in shellfish
called saxotoxin.
And saxotoxin
is also a potent
sodium channel
blocker and is going
to produce therefore
similar symptoms
like you see in
TTX poisoning.
and finally i mean
there's a plenty of list
of of channel blockers
that exist in nature
i'm just showing you
know a small number
here and focusing on
those channels that we
talked about in the
generation of action
potentials like voltage
-gated sodium and voltage
-gated potassium channels
the last one i'll
mention for now is
the um is dendrotoxin
dendrotoxin,
which is a potent
potassium channel
blocker found in
the venom of the
green mamba snake.
And because it's
blocking K channels,
right, not sodium
channels, it's blocking
K channels, which
are important for the
repolarization,
right, so what's going
to happen is it's
going to disrupt the
natural cycle of the
action potential of
the depolarization,
repolarization
phasing phases and so
it's going to prolong
action potentials
it's going to affect
all kinds of neural
function and when it
affects the cardiovascular
system of course then
you can have you know
ultimately death due
to these due to this
disruption again
relating kind of clinic
Clinical medicine, clinical
approaches to basic
biology is the
mechanism of action of
lidocaine, right? So
lidocaine is a great
sodium channel blocker that
is used in a lot
of local anesthetic
applications, right? In
dentistry and in, you know,
peripheral cuts, all
kinds of different
formulations are out
there, including creams,
right? Pain-relieving
cream with lidocaine,
4% lidocaine, and
patches that you could
put on the skin for
back pain or any number
of symptoms that you
might have. right? And
so here is the
schematic of the voltage
-gated sodium channel
protein here, and what we
can see there's a
portion of the channel
that has binding sites
for lidocaine, and
essentially what
lidocaine does then it's
going to block the
channel pore from fluxing
sodium, and then this
is going to shut down
action potentials. If
those action potentials
are from cells in
the periphery, for
example, that are
sending pain signals
to the central nervous
system, then by
shutting down those
action potentials, you
can relieve pain, right?
So here is a great
application of our
biomedical sciences
understanding about
neurons and their
physiology towards a
treatment for treating
localized pain,
all right?
A couple of years ago,
there was some good
clinical trial data
that came out for
a new voltage-gated
sodium channel blocker
that can be used for
post-surgical pain
in the New England
Journal of Medicine.
I believe it was used
for patients after
abdominal surgery and
bunion surgery and
note that both of
those procedures are
associated with intense
post-surgical pain.
What's neat about this
kind of pharmacological
approach is that it
targets the NAV 1.8
voltage-gated sodium
channel, which is
specifically expressed
in dorsal root ganglion
neurons and not in
central nervous system
neurons. Remember that
these DRG cells are
the ones that send
pain signals from the
periphery up to the
central nervous system.
And it's not a good
idea to give sodium
channel blockers in
the brain because that
could lead to sensory
and motor deficits.
But if there's a
unique channel in the
periphery that can be
targeted for specific
pain pathways up to the
brain, well then that
kind of drug is perfect
for pain relief.
And in the context
of a lot of opiate
use and *****,
finding new drugs for
the treatment of pain
is really important.
Well this drug
received FDA approval
this year and is
called Jornavax.
And here's a little
cartoon from the
Dronevax web page
that kind of has
some patient
education and you
can see they show
here pain signals
are created by
injury or surgery.
Dronevax works
in the peripheral
nervous system
what to block pain
signals before they
reach the brain.
So this is another great
example of applying
our biomedical
sciences knowledge in
the development of new
medicines for pain.
We can talk about
voltage-gated sodium
channels for the
whole year, but I'll
leave you with this
last slide, which
describes voltage
-gated sodium channel
gene mutations affecting
peripheral nervous
system neurons
that cause pain
syndromes. Now, depending
on the mutation,
some mutations
cause the channel
function to have
increased activity.
So in this case,
increased activity of
voltage-gated sodium
channels is going
to cause too many
action potentials,
right, and therefore
abnormal pain signals
sent to the CNS.
And there are two
conditions of note. One
is called inherited
primary erythromyalgia
and this is caused
by an activating
mutation of the NAV
1.8 voltage gated
sodium channel which
we just talked about.
And this is a rare
syndrome of intermittent
red hot painful
extremities usually
affecting the lower
extremities. And there's a
picture right here of
those red extremities
you might see in this
affected patient.
Another mutation affecting
the NAV 1.7 channel
in DRG neurons is
called familial episodic
pain syndrome.
Somewhat similar to the
one we just discussed,
but a little bit
different in its
presentation but again these
mutations cause increased
abnormal activity
which is then translates
into increased pain
symptoms right now
let's contrast that
with mutations that
affect channel function
by reducing channel
activity this is going
to produce too few
action potentials and
reduced pain signals
sent to the CNS. And a
different flavor of
mutations affecting the
NAV 1.7 causes a syndrome
called congenital
pain insensitivity,
congenital pain insensitivity,
also known as
congenital analgesia.
And in this condition,
you see near complete
absence of pain
perception associated with
noxious stimuli. These
patients have pain,
therefore end up with
painless injuries,
right? They have injuries
that they don't perceive
beginning in infancy,
but they have
otherwise normal sensory
modalities. So I hope
discussing how sodium
channels play a role
in the action potential,
how pharmacological
treatments target
voltage-gated
sodium channels and
how gene mutations
affect pain
perception kind of
hopefully brings
it all together.
So in conclusion
to this part of the
presentation, the
neuronal membrane contains
voltage-gated sodium and
potassium channels that
contribute to action
potential generation.
Action potentials
have different and
distinct phases, which
are produced by sequential
opening and closing
of voltage-gated
sodium and potassium
channels. Action potentials
can be modified by
ion channel blockers
such as TTX, lidocaine,
and we saw adronovax.
And gene mutations
affecting voltage
-gated sodium channels
produce pain syndromes.
All right, so now we
want to put together
what we understand.
All right, so
let's look at the
example now when the
presynaptic neuron
releases glutamate
as its neurotransmitter.
All right, so we have
the action potential
from the presynaptic
neuron depolarizing
the terminal voltage
-gated calcium
channels, vesicular
exocytosis of glutamate
in this case. So
glutamate, here is
our green dots into
the synaptic cleft,
right? And when
glutamate binds to
its glutamate
receptor, in this case
the AMPA, A-M-P
-A, AMPA receptor,
it opens a pore, and
that pore is permeable
to sodium and
potassium. But because
the driving force
for sodium is so
high, the sodium
rushes into the cell,
depolarizing more than
K leaving the cell.
And that depolarization
is going to be
visible as a membrane
potential change in the
postsynaptic neuron.
And you can see that
as a little blip of
excitation, a little blip
of depolarization
closer to zero, right?
if this is zero but note
that that depolarization
is pretty small
that could be about
you know two or three
millivolts three millivolts
right so from minus
65 to about minus
62 for example and
what that means is that
one individual cell might
not excite the neuron
enough to get it to
Let's say minus 40
and then trigger an
action potential in the
postsynaptic cell.
Instead, this is where the,
what nature created is
these large dendritic
trees, the complex
dendrites, so that lots
of neurons can be
talking to each other,
lots of inputs,
synaptic inputs onto the
dendrites of a neuron.
And if a lot of those
are active at once,
then all of these EPSPs,
excitatory postsynaptic
potentials, EPSPs,
will be bigger and
bigger and bigger. They
will summate, and that
neuron will get to minus
40 and trigger its
own action potential,
and that action potential
will travel down
that neuron's axon
and then connect to a
muscle, for example, right?
So the action potential
induced release of
glutamate into the
cleft will result in
sodium rushing into the
postsynaptic cell,
depolarizing the neuron,
and which then might
also contribute to
action potential
generation. And here we have
an example where there
were recordings in
the presynaptic
cells, cell 1, and the
postsynaptic cells, cell
2. And you can see every
time the neuron fires
an action potential,
we see a postsynaptic
response because
these cells are connected,
right? The response
could be small, so
this is only going to
be one or two millivolts,
but at least there's
this reliable
communication, all right?
And if we look at
the timing of this
communication, most
of the responses
that you record
in the postsynaptic
cell happen at about
one latent one millisecond
latency and here
we have some um little
video of some epsps
excitatory postsynaptic
potentials recorded
in a neuron this
neuron you could see is
about at minus 75 resting
membrane potential
so each one of these
little blips that you
see some are bigger
some are a little
smaller. All of these are
examples of transmitter
being released
presynaptically and binding
to this cell that was
being recorded and
then ion flow into the
cell. In this case,
you know,
likely mostly
sodium because
this is depolarizing
the cell.
Let's contrast what
we covered for the
glutamate synapses
with our gap with a
GABA synapse that
will hyperpolarize
postsynaptic neurons
all right how does this
come about instead of
release of glutamate
we have release of
GABA after an action
potential and
voltage-gated calcium
channel opening and
GABA will bind to its
postsynaptic receptor
right let's say on
the dendrite of the
postsynaptic neuron
And that receptor opens
a pore permeable to
chloride. Chloride has
a negative charge to
it. And so when
chloride rushes into the
cell, it's hyperpolarizing
the cell, making
it more negative, right?
So the response that
you'll see is more
negative here. And that's
called the inhibitory
postsynaptic potential.
So if our cell was
hanging out at about
minus 62, let's say,
when the presynaptic
neuron fires an action
potential, releases
GABA, it's going to
hyperpolarize the cell.
And that makes the
postsynaptic cell less
likely to fire an
action potential, right?
because it is moving
further away from let's
say minus 40 where it
would need to hit to
to trigger an
action potential. So
the action potential
in the presynaptic
neuron induces
release of GABA.
Ionotropic GABA
receptors have a chloride
pore. Chloride rushes
into the cell due to the
concentration gradient
making it harder for
the postsynaptic
neuron to fire action
potentials. And here in
this example where we
where the pre-synaptic
neuron and the post
-synaptic neuron were
recorded together, you can
see for every action
potential that you can
that you have, you
have a little blip of
hyperpolarization in
the post-synaptic cell.
All right, we're
going to contrast real
quick here the
chemical synapses with
electrical synapses. So
we talked about those
briefly in the earlier
lecture. This is
not neurotransmitter
based, right, and
it's not even action
potential dependent.
This kind of synapse
can, you know, can
be is active all the
time in the sense
that there are these
pores, right, that
are linking. So
here's our electrical
synapse. We're going
to zoom in on it. We
have these channels,
these connection
channels, that are
pores that allow ion and
small molecule flow
between the cells.
So these are
going to be active
all the time.
And if we were
to inject a dye
into this cell,
that dye would
go through the
gap junction to
the other cell.
Many different kinds
of changes in one
neuron would be
reflected in the other
neuron. all right now
it is the case that
even though these
guys have electrical
synapses there's still an
influence of the
action potential
in one cell
versus the other
so there is an influence
still of the action
potential at at gap
junctions in that
when when one neuron
fires an action potential
right and remember
sodium and potassium
are running into and
out of the cell during
the action potential,
you will see a
membrane potential
change in the other
postsynaptic neuron
connected by gap junctions.
Now, this is not
mediated by transmitter,
right? This is just
direct ion flow of, let's
say, sodium rushing
from one cell into the
other, right? So that's
where it's different
than the chemical
synapses. And so for
each action potential in
the presynaptic neuron,
you'll see a little
blip in the postsynaptic
cell. And of course,
this is depolarizing
the cell, and this
could contribute to
action potential generation
in that postsynaptic
neuron, right? And
again, the name of the
game is how are neurons
communicating with
each other to produce
behavior, to produce
movement, to produce
emotion, etc. These are
all the different
ways that neurons are
connected and how they
can communicate, right?
All right, and
this kind of
communication is
very, very fast.
All right, let's kind
of put it all together
in a neat example of
where we have the nerve,
we have neurons, we
have synapses, we have
axons, dendrites, etc.
We're going to put
it all together in the
patellar tendon reflex,
which is an amazing
example of how neuronal
connections and synaptic
physiology creates
behavior. In this
case, we have the
sensation, and we have
the movement response,
right? So, everybody
knows the doctor hits the
patella. It lengthens
the muscle. Here, in
this case, the quad.
Inside the muscle,
there are muscle
spindles, which are axons
that wrap around the
muscle fiber, right?
And if we zoom in on
this little patch of
the axon, right, the
sensory neuron axon,
we'll see how it wraps
around the muscle
fiber. If we zoom in
on that even further,
we'll see that there
are channels, right?
This is how we have
to think about the
brain. We always have
neurons, their membranes,
the channels, etc.
And these channels
are mechanically
gated, right? So as
the muscle stretches,
the axon membrane
is stretching.
These channels
are mechanically
activated. They
are going to
open and allow
sodium to rush in.
Sodium rushes into
the sensory neuron.
Sodium is going
to depolarize the
cell. If it depolarizes
the cell enough,
it is going to
open voltage-gated
sodium channels that
are also on here.
If they open voltage
-gated sodium channels,
it's going to
cause an action
potential. So now this
neuron generates an
action potential,
right? And that signal
is going to travel
down the axon. Here's
the DRG, dorsal
ruganglion. That action
potential is going to
travel to the terminal,
right? And this
sensory neuron, this 1A
afferent, right, encoding
muscle length here
at the muscle spindle
is going to do what?
It's going to synapse
on the dendrites
of a alpha motor neuron,
right? So we have
axon, terminal, synapse
at the dendrite.
The 1A afferent neuron
releases glutamate.
What does glutamate
do? It's going to want
to depolarize the alpha
motor neuron as if
it depolarizes it enough
we're going to get
voltage gated sodium
channels that open on
the alpha motor neuron
and that action potential
is going to travel
to the muscle to the
uh to the synapse from
the motor neuron to
the muscle right and
that synapse is a very
special synapse you'll
learn a lot about.
The alpha motor
neuron releases
acetylcholine at
the muscle and
acetylcholine can then
trigger excitation
of the muscle.
Let's go over that.
First let's look at
you know the the alpha
motor neuron synapses
on the muscle fiber.
It's a very highly
specialized synapse that
kind of looks here's
that that here's the
synaptic cleft very
very interesting
invaginations here we have
our little transmitter
vesicles right so let's
put it all together
all right so let's
keep putting this all
together and including
all the different
concepts that
we've covered so
far. We have our
sensory neuron
that projects to
our motor neuron
and an action
potential in the
sensory neuron is
going to release
glutamate at this
synapse here,
right?
If it depolarizes the
motor neuron enough,
this motor neuron will
fire an action potential
as well. That action
potential will travel
down the myelinated
axon until it reaches
the axon terminal, the
special synapse that
we know of as the
neuromuscular junction.
The action potential
depolarizes the terminal
and voltage-gated
calcium channels open,
depolarize the terminal,
And then we can
see here, as we zoom
in further and further
at this special
synapse, we have
transmitter, and we see
the postsynaptic muscle
elements here. Let's
zoom in even further,
right? Depolarization
of the axon terminal
is going to cause
vesicles to be exocytosed
at the presynaptic terminal,
right? Acetylcholine
is released at this
synapse right at
the neuromuscular
junction and acetylcholine
will bind to the
acetylcholine receptor in
this case that's the
nicotinic receptor right
and this receptor
allows sodium to rush
in and potassium rushes
out but more sodium
rushes in than potassium
leaving, so you have
a net depolarization
of the muscle fiber.
Depolarization
of the end plate
is going to cause
voltage-gated
sodium channels
in the muscle
to depolarize
and that then
produces the
action potential.
So I hope you can see
how we can integrate
all the different concepts
that we've discussed
on top of the neural
circuitry to understand
how you get muscle
contraction and
behavior in the patellar
tendon reflex or any
kind of sensory motor
circuit that exists. And
obviously, the patellar
tendon reflex is an
important clinical
evaluation tool, right?
So, synaptic transmission,
or the physiology
of synapses, has a
lot of different, you
know, elements to it,
like we've mentioned.
And in each of these
parts, you know, we have
discussed underlying
anatomy and physiology.
We didn't talk too
much about reuptake or
reuptake of transmitter.
You'll cover that in
your neurochemistry
lecture, but obviously
this is going to be
a critical element to
this whole cycle and of
neuron communication.
And we also
didn't talk about
neurotransmitter
breakdown, but all of
these different
concepts are areas
where disease can
emerge, right? Disease
can emerge when you
have something wrong
with action potential
generation or something
wrong with transmitter
reuptake or
something wrong with
post-synaptic transmitter
receptors, right? So
that's kind of how
we get the biomedical
mechanisms of disease
and why it's important
we know about
these different concepts.
And I'll give you
two more quick examples.
One is clinical
correlations. One is
Lambert-Eaton syndrome.
In Lambert-Eaton
syndrome, patients
develop autoantibodies
for the voltage-gated
calcium channels. So
now these channels
are not working
properly because of
autoantibodies, right?
So, obviously, this is
going to affect
transmitter release, right?
Particularly at the
neuromuscular junction
is where you see
these symptoms, right?
So, symptoms include
muscle weakness throughout
the body, especially
limbs and face, as
well as autonomic
symptoms. And the treatment
options are going
to be at trying to,
regulate what's
going on here, block
the immune response,
or try to increase
voltage-gated calcium
channel function.
Another great example
is myasthenia gravis
that you might have
covered. In this disorder,
patients produce
autoantibodies against
the acetylcholine
receptor. So here we have
our normal neuromuscular
junction and
acetylcholine being
released and our normal
acetylcholine receptors.
But here we have
acetylcholine receptor
antibodies that are now
affecting the function
of that receptor, which
then causes symptoms
somewhat similar to
Lambert-Eaton, right?
weakness but obviously
this is a different site
a different mechanistic
site of where the
deficit is localized
it's not in the voltage
gated calcium channel
in this case it's
at the postsynaptic
receptor so we talked
about membrane potentials
we talked about
action potentials here
we talked about synaptic
connections and the
physiology right and
we covered we said
neurons are connected to
one another via chemical
and electrical synapses.
The postsynaptic
effect of a given
neurotransmitter will
depend on the type of
transmitter itself,
right, like glutamate or
GABA, and you'll learn
more about actual
different ion channels,
excuse me, postsynaptic
receptors. We talked
about two ionotropic
examples, one glutamate
and one GABA, and
then of course all the
players that we've
talked about in in these
first two lectures
neurons channels myelin
transmitters etc are
involved in synaptic
transmission they're
vulnerable sites to produce
disease and are also
then druggable targets
for therapies please
reach out if you have
any questions and
you to fill out this
feedback form when you
get a chance take care